as chair of the house ways and means
committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor
as a result of clover 19 pandemic
in accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a work session on
remaining bills ways and means committee
executive session on pending
legislations may be also be held
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporariously to
this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporariously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
and the public has access to
contemporaries listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available
in calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules
and rsa 91a anyone who has a problem
accessing the meeting should call 271
or email hcs at lake.state.nh.us
in the event is unable to access the
meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that are
on the meeting assisting us
jennifer flora committee researcher
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting
shall be done by roll call vote let's
start by meeting
the meeting by taking a roll call of
attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state
whether there is anyone in the room with
you during the meeting
which is required under the right to
know law so
representative bernstein would you take
the role
thank you mr chair today is march 2nd
2021 it's 9 a.m let's begin roll call
with representative patrick abrami
you're my home in stratham my wife's in
the house
subbing for mary griffin is
representative wayne mcdonald
good morning i'm uh here and i'm home
alone
representative jordan owerry
yes i'll be in my car taking my wife to
the doctor's office but i'll be
she'll be with me during that time
representative russ
ober here in hudson at my home with
sorry about that good morning uh my home
office salem alone
good morning uh representative burshteen
that's me
is in his home office in nottingham new
hampshire by himself
representative elliott i'm here in my
uh apartment and my wife is uh
in some other room representative
jeanine
i'm home uh in salem and my wife is
somewhere in the house
representative nunes thank you
representative bergstein i'm home alone
in pelham
representative baxter thank you
representative
home alum representative stillsbury
good morning home uh in charlestown my
wife is elsewhere in the house
representative tudor i'm home in
northwood alone
representative susan homie i'm in
lebanon alone
representative ames i'm here in jeffrey
in my home office alone
representative southward here in dover
alone representative malloy here
alone in greenland representative thomas
schamberg
i'm here in wilmette in my uh office and
my wife is in her office
representative tucker i'm here
alone in randolph representative gomarlo
alone and swansea representative
laughman
representative tom lofton representative
gorg
i am present and alone representative
hacken phillips good morning i'm
president for my office alone in concord
representative james murphy good morning
i'm here
over in my home office alone
representative norman major
good morning i'm in my home and my wife
is in
the other room mr chair there are 23
thank you representative
okay today
we're going to deal with the remaining
bills that we've had public hearings on
which is 12 bills
we also have five other bills the
second committee bills which i'll
wednesday march 10th
because tuesday march 9th is election
day so
everybody will be out that day
12 bills that we have left i'm going to
discuss today
is we can break them up into two groups
one that has to do with the dra
type bills which is house bill
10 15 210 252
504 and 568
and the non-dra ones
which are cacr 1 2
house bill 346 400
we're going to start by taking
one from the non-dra one which is house
bill
626 has to do with gambling
and why we're doing that is charlie
mcintyre
should be in attendance
will be available to answer questions on
that
i'm letting them in thank you
and then after we do house bill 626
then we're going to go into the dra
related ones because we have
members from the dra which are in
attendance
we'll be able to answer questions from
house bill 10 i'm going to hold that
so we will start with house bill 626
six bills house bill 626
and that relative to historic horse
racing
is the prime sponsor on that
representative doucet
a member of the committee is also on
that bill
and a number of others
so the discussion the starting was up to
me
he wants to start the discussion on rep
thank you on i want
to understand
why this bill
and this new initiative in
fairly major gambling
on is does not allow
the local option that is
provided in keno and provided in sports
betting
last term when this came through on
as chair i was pretty limited in
asking things and um
it was a total
surprise to me when i was told that we
don't do this
well we did in the last two years before
that
do this and um
i would there because it has been put
within charitable gaming statute
but is also linked to the racing statute
on it goes um
it's taking the most freedoms
for this activity uh
individual freedoms on
from the charitable gaming
and and
but it is actually an activity
which would normally be considered to be
in a totally new chapter all by itself
because
it is uh quite a departure from
everything that has been considered
charitable gaming in the past and
i would like to know uh
whether um people would be willing
to support putting a local
option for this activity
as you know charitable gaming has been
around for almost a decade and a half
there's never ever been a local option
having to do with charitable gaming
these organizations have sprouted up
there's 16 of 16 of them now throughout
playing variety of games from
craps to roulette to
and not once
has a community ever voted on any of
those
on any of those whether it be poker
or whether it be roulette or whatever
now keno and i was involved in the
keynote
and actually i i insisted on
an opt-in up for that way back when
because it was a different kind of
facility it was
a a restaurant
that poured liquor and that was
different enough
that we said we should have an opt-in
by the community for keno
and that has gone on and has been
that past and many communities have
since
voted in uh the local option for that
but all we're doing with this bill back
to
historic racing is adding another game
to the portfolio of games that already
exist
so uh within charitable gaming
and that's why i do not think it's
appropriate
to to have this option
now mr chair
mr chair representative ames
yeah i'd like to speak speak on that
question um in response to
what representative romney just said
i think there's a difference here
the horse racing machines that we're
talking about
uh bring a scale to charitable gaming
that's
unprecedented uh we're talking about
on average according to the fiscal note
the fiscal note of course is a
guesstimate but they used 1 000 machines
statewide as basis for the estimate
you divide that by 16. and you get about
odd machines per site but it's going to
be uneven they're going to be some with
much more many more and some with less
that's a big hit for a local community
and
it's a it's a question of
that should be
[Music]
answered it's it's the placement of a
facility with
those machines in it is a
is a matter that should be i think
put to the local voters to see whether
they uh
agree that it's okay it's very different
from
keno very different from anything else
that
we've talked about and
for kino now sports betting we have
local options
why not for this i don't understand it
and we're talking by the way
in terms of scale i mentioned a thousand
machines the fiscal
note also points out that if that's the
number of machines we're gonna have 550
million dollars flowing through
um those 16 locations
that's a lot of money it's a lot of
money
and so one more
difference between this proposal and
everything else
that's involved with uh related to
charitable gaming
uh respond to that mr chair could i
respond first
i did have my hand up with me
okay followed by representative romney
thank you on we have been very careful
over the years in charitable gaming they
have come to us
with requests for machines
the major difference of a machine from
the
poker and the roulette and the the
craps is that
there is only an interaction between an
individual person
and a machine not the social component
that is found
in re in what used to be charitable
gaming
and what on when we have had machine
requests
when we have granted them we have been
very careful
to circumscribe them enough actually
that the
people running large gambling
establishments
uh wanted keep coming back to say
let us get rid of these circumstances
and we have said no
because they were meant to just be
a convenience not something that would
draw someone in to spend all of their
time
in front of that machine on
these are
a class of machine
which is set up
specifically to keep someone
on the machine as long as possible
and gambling as quickly as possible
on that creates
more problems with people who lose
all of their money they are not a very
large percentage
of the people that use those machines
because most people
on do not addict
but the closer you live to these places
the more you addict the more likely you
addict
and there are communities where
this is considered to be not so much
problem
one it's in the culture two
on it's serving a very
very large area of people um
there are also communities that now have
charitable gaming
where this is a huge problem because
as in my community they have been the
poker room has been put
in the middle of the
subsidized housing and the housing for
people who are
recovering from substance abuse uh the
housing of elder people
who don't have much to do in their lives
and don't have enough enough money
probably to last for very long without
ending up
in the county on nursing home
and so communities
communities need to have some kind of
say
in this major difference from what we
have been doing
so far thank you thank you
representative
representative okay three things
uh first let's not forget that we in
many of these
establishments already have lucky seven
machines
which are mechanical devices that take
bets just like these
uh and some of them have
some have 30 30 35 of these machines
in a facility uh so this is not the
first time
there's mechanical devices uh
the other thing that we neglect to talk
about we haven't talked about
was that many communities use ordinances
when it comes to regulating its their
charitable gaming
salem salem is a great example of that
they indicate where in the community
they wanted to see charitable gaming
uh so there are mechanisms that
exist to monitor or to
place within a community uh charitable
gaming
that are that already are uh
a town can avail themselves to
now as far as the machines themselves
and talking to charlie mcintyre over the
years he always says
the easiest thing for him to maintain
our machines
it's harder for him to maintain and and
monitor poker
to monitor the crap stable
because there's human beings involved
interacting
not just the machine and maybe
perhaps mr mr chair perhaps
we can have charlie just chime in a
second on that the whole issue of
his ability to oversee this
and uh comparing it to
other other games of chance that he has
to maintain
and monitor would that be okay yes
charlie charlie mcintyre
yes good morning mr chair members of the
committee hi charlie mcintyre
i'm at my office in concord with me is
our chief compliance officer
uh john conforti who's been before the
you heard what the discussion was
relative to the machines
i did i did um one of the things
the technology exists certainly to
monitor the machines in real time
uh similar to what we do with lottery
terminals and they are the
from the purposes of a regulatory
standpoint the easiest to maintain
and one of the things i wanted to
comment on that we said earlier is
while the fiscal note contains a very
large number
that's not the amount of money that goes
into the machine that's the amount of
money
a play that exists and what i mean by
that is if you put ten dollars into a
terminal
ultimately you're going to play probably
somewhere between
forty fifty dollars worth of play sixty
dollars worth of play
seventy a significant number above the
amount you put
in before that money is exhausted so
really what we generally concern
ourselves with is what's left at the end
of the day
that remains in the machine and
similarly
i'll use the analogy to sports betting
um sports betting will do oh probably
600 million dollars full year in sports
betting activity
but it's not like 600 million dollars is
passed through our term
our machines it's really you know the
same fifty dollars is going back and
forth across people who bet
and it's you know i bet fifty dollars
and representative measurement sixty
dollars in the same game
on opposite sides one fifty dollars has
gone from one account to another account
um so similarly the machines themselves
don't
get all of that money it's not like
someone puts in hundreds of millions of
dollars
they're putting in millions there's no
question but it's
if you're playing you're said depositing
ten dollars
you you better you better quarter you
win 10 cents back you bet a quarter
again you win 50 cents back
you lose three times you lose 75 cents
so it's this constant play
that makes it a much larger number than
it sounds like if that and
so for our purposes um
you know i we're giant fans of
technologies you can imagine they're far
more easy to monitor to answer your
question
mr chairman well thank you charlie
are there any other questions about
charlie's yes i
i do representative ames
yeah uh related to what you just
i'm going to put together several
questions and i think it's easier for
you
to answer these but um related to your
point about the
the actual amount being less than that
545 million dollars
that that i had mentioned
fair enough but it is still a lot of
money and i think you said that
um and uh and i'd like
way in which you ensure that that that
money
is managed appropriately it's more than
just the machine
it's there's a lot of money um
that is uh maybe it's
our credit card's being used i don't
know maybe you could go into all that
question of how the money gets played
related to this money question is your
fiscal note
and in the fiscal note you uh you used
a thousand machines as your takeoff
point
um this and that's the same
and it's basically the same note as you
did
two years ago for the bill that was then
put forward on the same issue
and this year we've got a bill that has
a debt limit of 25
at that time the bet limit was 10
dollars
i don't see any adjustment for that in
your fiscal note
um is that uh because it doesn't need to
be
and if so why so maybe you could speak
to that too
i think that's the main things right now
charlie yep sorry i shouldn't speak too
well with technology when i do that
right
um i'll answer i'll answer in reverse
order if i can the represent of ames
i see the bet limit um 10 or 25
to me the difference in terms of handle
would be a material
i wouldn't see a large difference in the
amount of wagering activity
not a lot of folks will have a bet a
single bet above ten dollars
on a machine like this generally what
you have is you have folks who
go with a budget a set amount of money
and look to play for a long time and so
um it's it's unlikely you would have a
large amount of play at 25
or even above 10 so that's why the
fiscal doesn't change
um and the number of machines
honestly i don't know the answer to that
based on the number of facilities
it would determine how many machines
there are what type
and how they're configured um
handled up to your point um well i say
that the amount of
uh money is not 547 there's no question
that in our fiscal note
and the amount of money that actually
goes through these facilities is 65
million dollars so i don't discount the
amount of money in question
it's a large sum of money it's just not
the big number which can sometimes get
inflated uh or it can be
scary because it's such a large number
um
and we certainly over the last several
years as we incorporated
racing and charitable gambling we
increased our financial audit capacity
significantly
um for the first time in our history of
the last two years we've audited every
room
in our under our umbrella
we regularly audit charities to make
sure they the the revenues are correct
and i think i've said before when we
first absorbed this agency
we sent out 500 subpoenas to everybody
involved in the process to make sure
everybody's numbers were correct
and by and large we found that the
numbers were correct which was a
assumption that i didn't make originally
but certainly came to
after taking over this agency
and we will beef up our regulatory
staff as well there's a companion bill
filed by representative abrami related
to um
compliance and investigation division
which you folks
voted ought to pass um do they get
transferred edna
but certainly looking to beef up our
investigatory functions
and powers of the division um and we do
have
open positions currently that are funded
not filled that we will also add to
um that division i know john once
and john grifford wants that any
question eddie said
so just to representative ames point um
with an increase
in uh money coming into these facilities
we would also
increase our oversight of anti-money
laundering
um so a lot of these rooms would be
subject to federal requirements
regarding
uh suspicious activity reporting um
and uh and reporting any
large tier transactions um and we
we are monitoring that in some of the
rooms where we've had sports betting
we've uh
we have had the rooms implement uh
federally compliant anti-money
laundering policies so on the front end
in the room itself we're making sure
that the cash
handling and cash reporting activities
uh are being done to
federal legal standards um and then as
uh
as charlie said uh on the back end
we have a robust audit program that
we've built out over the last couple
years
to be able to go into every facility
every few months
um to take to take a look at their books
uh to take a look at their financial
reporting
and to do a pretty um focused audit
to make sure that uh that the financial
reporting
uh both to the state and then also
making sure that the charities are
getting
uh their fare cut based on the statutory
percentage
and obviously we would extend that out
to the historic horse racing
activities as well as charlie said as we
get more activity we're going to need
more bodies but we have
the the programs and procedures in place
right now based on our games of chance
follow-up follow-up representative ames
um i appreciate those answers that's
good information and thank you
you're doing good work there um
so uh two two questions one is uh on the
bet limit
you said it really wouldn't make that
much difference and uh
my my question is why why raise the debt
limit
to uh to 25 if
most bettors will get below ten dollars
and then uh the other question
uh is machines and uh
you're using a thousand machines just as
a way of doing this
analysis i understand that but i would
expect that there would be
a pretty significant difference in the
across the 16 locations
and i've got i think a thousand by 16
divided by 16 is about 60 but that's
just an
average so what's your
best guesstimate of how this is going to
the spread of the machines across the
state
certainly um if i recall correctly
there's no magic to the 25
i think it was meant to comport with the
largest ticket
that the lottery can sell so under the
rsa's related to the lottery the largest
ticket size is 25 and it comports with
that
so i think that's the answer to that
question representative ames there was
no
magic to it so that wasn't our idea it
was just i think somebody asked what's
the biggest bet the lottery can place
and it's 25 um as for the map of
machines
i would certainly um if i was building
it out
and if the marketplace was speaking
correctly
i would assume the vast majority of
machines would be in rocky and
hillsborough county
locations down that way and as close to
population centers as could possibly be
imagined
uh and so the plurality of the machines
to the majority would likely be near or
at the last border
and the facilities there um only because
the marketplace can handle them there
versus locations where there's not much
population so the distribution would not
be
16 dividing dividing but dividing a
thousand
it would be something different than
that
okay um representative
gord
thank you um i have a question
probably for representative almi i'm
curious
if there's an a way to
change the percentages that go to
our nonprofits if this is truly
charitable gaming
i just i'm a little concerned just from
someone who used to run a nonprofit that
the the numbers just seemed
really small um and i didn't know if
there was a way to
um change
what it just seems like a bad deal for
the state as well but is there a way to
kind of change
and that was a question to represent yes
please i think or
uh representative you want to respond
first and then
oh i'm the last person to ask that too
i think it would be uh to mr mcintyre
about on why we have to give so much
money to the operators for this
but i i wanted to follow up later as
soon as i can with with miss mcintyre
thank you
charlie did you want to respond to
representative forks
certainly um because these machines are
not
what you would call video lottery
terminals or which is called the
vernacular
slot machines they're not
as attractive as they would be if they
were so
uh the percentage that the operator gets
is to sort of
reimburse them for all the cost of
operations the facility itself the labor
costs
our compliance requirements which will
be onerous
um the machines themselves also want to
on a rev share
so a machine manufacturer will take a
percentage of the amount that machine
gets
to reimburse it into profit as a going
business um
i mean that's the reason it's these you
know 65 million dollars divided by six
to 16 facilities
it's not obviously a one for one but
that's not
a large number it's not a large revenue
for a business
that has to maintain a significant
amount of uh requirements
so that's that's the way it sits
if these were vlts the number will be
much much higher
but they're not um and so that's where
it is
representative thank you for taking my
question i want to
uh follow up with what representative
gorg uh
pointed out about that percentage uh
and uh i also
uh so that that's she's she brought that
up that's out on the table now
um and i would like to uh see that
percentage increased
it goes to the non-profits end of the
state the uh
but my my uh
other question if i may or my
comment is you know in uh
in an effort to uh put in full
transparency i
um agree with representative almi
that um we should think about a local
option here because i think if local
voters knew what that percentage was and
how much was not going to
uh the non-profits and the state
they may have a different opinion about
whether or not they want to expand this
because it looks very tiny and
is not a number that i would want to
have to defend
[Music]
i think you'll find mr chair
i think you'll find if you go if you dig
down into the numbers
that the number's actually fair number
and
remember we we passed a this this body
passed a
uh a commission or a joint committee
with the senate
we can address all of these issues uh
because
this is again broader than just
charitable gaming
uh then uh excuse me then uh then
historic racing machines
if you're going to bring this type of
topic up i think you're going to bring
it up
for all of charitable gaming why aren't
the charities getting more in general
is it's a broader question than just
historic racing machines
and again that could be addressed but i
think
what you need to do is do an honest
honest assessment of
what's a reasonable margin someone in
business
doing this and i've looked at it
different ways and it seems like this is
a reasonable margin
for the risk that they're taking uh
to uh to put this out there
and again remember we're talking about
adding 5.7 million dollars to the
charities
12 million dollars to the education
trust fund
at 821 000 in the
uh problem gambling fund
uh through this through just this action
of
of historic racing so
um you know it looks on paper you look
at it you go wow
yeah but they got to turn the lights on
they got to turn the heat on
they gotta buy the machines they got to
do all this other stuff
uh that's that is required in running a
business
so i'll leave it at that and i'm not
believe me
if i thought if i personally thought
that that these facilities were making
too much
i wouldn't be the prime sponsor of this
bill
thank you uh before we go to
actually representative said but before
that
the point i want to make
representative and representative
malloy's question
is that we had slews and slews of
correspondence
from various charities in support of
this bill
but i don't remember one charity
that was against this bill
and the charities why are they out
supporting this bill if they think
they're getting
too little so that's the question
representative decided
thank you mr chairman just uh to this
point i i happen to have
the numbers in front of me as an example
out of a 100 dollar
wage made 92 dollars of that is paid
back
to the player 2.50 is paid back
paid out to the state and the charity
two dollars and fifty cents is paid to
the
machine manufacturer of the software
licensing etc
uh operating expenses of two dollars and
forty cents and
we don't have to go through that list
but the uh the end result is
60 cents or point six percent
of that hundred dollar bet goes to the
operators and
two point five percent go to the both
the charity in the state so
uh it's in line with with other
representative naomi you have your hands
up
i do i'm not new at this point though i
am still trying to get back
okay you have a question to represent
for
mr mcintyre let's just state your
question
thank you on you as far as i can tell
are
only auditing for whether the money
that is uh earned extracted from
on the the users of the charitable
gaming
facility is correctly
on accounted for
and provided to the places it's supposed
to be provided to
what i am concerned with is
the people that become
problem gamblers because they are
in places that have one of these
facilities
on it is a very long way to a slot
machine
which is in massachusetts on
the research that was done by a
person that ran charitable
uh that would um that was funded
by the major casinos that was in
massachusetts for about 10 years before
he moved to texas
on showed that the people
that were near small casinos
in rhode island were spending small
amounts of money
in those casinos and going on weekends
because they'd gotten
gotten on very addicted to this
uh they they were going over to
connecticut
so that is a thing
now what i am most interested in
is how we can
identify and
and try to
help the people that come to these
facilities
because they are lonely because
on they they are
uh addictive personalities in the first
place
on and on become
on keep coming back and staying in front
of that machine for hours
because you have to accept
that when you have autocad on a machine
almost everybody is going to push the
autocad button
and treat it as a slow version
and not very slow version of a slot
machine it is a lot faster version than
some things we saw in the past
and what i want to ask mr mcintyre
is as i understand it
these machines are controlled from
the software and machine distributor
they are not controlled elsewhere
how can you try to put in controls
that will sh that will identify people
that are spending hours
at at one of these machines
so that your uh
enforcement arm and the chair the
uh problem gambling fund
on are capable of
dealing with for any gambling there is a
certain amount
of of addiction but for machines there
is much more so how
how can you find out who these people
are
and see if they are willing to ban
themselves
see uh see if they
charlie uh certainly um
representative alani uh to your point
certainly um
we can increase the amount of display
for responsible gaming
in each facility uh we can mandate
training
for the staff in questions of the 16
facilities
um adding controls to a machine is kind
of tricky
only because we're not going to you're
not going to know
if it's a new player an old player in a
machine
the machines themselves are obviously
tested so you know what you're getting
in terms of
the math behind it
one of the provisions is certification
by a testing lab
so the machines themselves are operating
within the specifications we dictate
in terms of help all we can do is sort
of
offer multiple aspects of multiple
communication channels
when it comes to folks who want help
one of the nice things about our
obviously our other platforms is they
have
exclusion lists that are because of the
technology
i mean certainly we could um offer an
exclusion list
for each facility as well and we could
offer that statewide
it does bring up enforcement
difficulties as you can imagine because
it's hard you know absent very expensive
technology
uh it's hard to manage that level of
exclusion
uh and even those i will tell you uh
somebody who's dealt in this
world for a long time um it's when
people take personal responsibility that
it really takes hold
not the government itself dictating
terms
can i have a follow-up can you
limit it to about two minutes yes
yes uh if i can on
first personal responsibility is
negated by addiction that is the problem
with addiction
on second on the major casinos
have ways of tracking all of this but it
is just
as you said pretty impossible to track
it
in these small tiny mini
places
possibly on the brook
could track it it's big enough to be a
casino
but on this is is something that
if if nothing can be done about this
it's going to overwhelm
charlie you want to respond
um i don't think that was the former
question mr chairman
um i think it was more informative of a
statement so
thank you okay uh
you have your hands up i did yes i had a
follow-up i'm so sorry
um first of all thank you a
representative giusette for going
through the breakdown it was really nice
that actually representative all me i
mean not me i'm sorry abrami sent
us all that breakdown so i thank you for
repeating it though
and to the chair um although yes
everybody look we got a lot of responses
from charitable
uh organizations it doesn't hurt to ask
for more
so i'm just gonna throw that out there
um
because nonprofits are where my heart is
so if i can get more money for them i'm
gonna ask
but i do have a question for um my
follow-up to
um mr mcintyre is what
um the operator's share and the amount
that the state gets and the operating
costs and all of that stuff is that on
par with other states that do
this historic racing representative um
thank you for the question and certainly
i've been remiss in not
telling the committee that um based on
the prior
filing of the bill related to study of
child gambling
unh to research this and so we sent out
a study to
all of our charities in question asking
them a series of questions related to
charitable gambling um that came from us
that didn't come from anybody and we're
paying for it ourselves
so that um how satisfied they are are
they getting what they want all these
things
and so as soon as we get the results
that we'll share them with everybody
um because we're giant research nuts
here so if
there's an issue you want to know about
it before we end so i wanted to
share that because i completely forgot
about it um
second also uh yes the answer is
uh this rate of we'll call it a tax rate
it's really just a rev share is
consistent with other states
uh kentucky wyoming virginia the three
that i would point to
and they're approximately the same
thank you mr chair uh commissioner
mcintyre
it appears that the um figures quoted by
representative doucet
coming from the the colorful sheet
we got this one um
[Music]
says 92 percent goes back to the players
but the fiscal note
it looks like 88 goes back to the
players
am i looking at this wrong
so for our purposes uh we work off of
the lowest common denominator and the
bill
says that a minimum of 88 percent has to
go back in prizes
so for us we use the minimum which is 88
and the 12
the remainder um
prize payout is one of those things that
we live and breathe by
and so depending upon how the machines
are manufactured and placed
in the facilities the price payout will
vary i wouldn't imagine that much it
will vary probably between 89 and 91
and so our take will be off of that i
think it was just done for ease of math
representative to that point um
by the same token i want to leave this
point very clear is
because there's less of a margin
does not mean there's less profit quite
the opposite
um lower margin in gambling generally
yields to higher profit
and i'll make that case for the lottery
side
our margin has gone down by i think five
percent over the last 10 years
and our profitability has gone up by
about 30 million
so um just because the margin is
different don't
look to a one-for-one overlap comparison
does that make sense to you yes it does
may i have a follow-up please
um so it depends on the way the machines
are uh manufactured as to what the odds
will be
correct it's really more because it's a
paramutual product it's more of the sort
of the
the races that win and the um
and how the machine is lays out the
specific odds and the specific payout
for specific races
okay thank you very much and it will
vary too representative garland it'll
vary by
which horses come through which what's
dates and what's times but it'll be
okay representative murphy thank you mr
chairman um
this is to commissioner uh just a simple
question do you know
uh regionally or nationally how many
people with this
historic betting um use the auto cap
function
i don't know the answer to that
apologize i don't i
emily thank you
i wanted to address the charity
area uh first they are
uh this is free money for the charities
second a huge percentage of those came
out of the city of nashua
on and third on
i explored this a little in my community
on there were several people that
on i approached who said that they
do not want to see this in our community
on i approached the rotary
club because they had actually signed up
with the poker club
and i was told we spent an enormous
amount of time arguing about whether
we wanted to get money from poker even
though a number of them
play poker uh most of them play poker
uh in friendly games on
and the idea on
a machine
operation is one that
is highly unacceptable
in our area on i don't say that that's
true
of nashua they're very close to the
massachusetts border
massachusetts on bets
more money per capita than i think
anywhere in the country
um so on they
they're interested in these things but
on
in my area no thank
is that a you of a question or just a
statement no it's a continuing
question about why we cannot have local
options
yeah i got it um
so i i i guess i've got one question for
mr mcintyre but uh then i've got a
couple of questions for
representative romney but i don't know
how you want to handle that
um the question
to uh mr mcintyre
is uh relates to the selection of
charities
um to participate in
um dates with the
operators and um my
question is whether what your rules
provide with what what boundary lines or
systems you have put in place
through rule for the selection of uh
of the charities that are going to
benefit from this charitable
gambling or is this all delegated to
uh operators the lottery takes no part
in choosing charities uh
that's left the operator representative
ames
okay now you have a question for
you have a question for representative
oh yes i do yeah
okay um so my question to you
representative romney is uh
is why uh okay
there's a couple of questions here why
you
chose to put forward in this bill
a bet limit of twenty five dollars
rather than ten dollars
and then um why
you chose not to include in this bill
the limitation that was
in the bill as sent forward
with amendment by the ways and means
limiting the use of the auto cap feature
and and then finally
whether you think it's okay that
gamble on these machines where we
require an age of 21 for
remember all the questions but is there
twenty five dollars versus ten dollars
uh the twenty five dollars i was told it
didn't matter really uh because most
people are only going to bet two or
three dollars
i was also told that there's a certain
vendor that
that has a trifecta kind of a bet
uh that could be a larger bet
so i said fine we'll put 25 but i was
told
in other locales no one bets 25
mr mcintyre mentioned uh people
people don't want to make one bet and
then
lose all their money and walk away they
want to play for the enjoyment of
playing
so that's that one the second question
is is
to be honest with you i totally forgot
about the the amendment
that was there from uh last last year i
guess it was last year
uh but you gotta remember about that
amendment
was that even though we had an amendment
that said there'd be no auto cap
there was still gonna be an auto cap
basically a manual auto cap
that people were going to we're going to
pick them or
they were going to choose an automatic
amount
without the machine doing it for them so
to me because i even went along with
that way back when
but i'd be honest with you i totally
forgot about that when i
when i refiled a bill so and that that
just came up recently
uh and i think your comments to me about
that
the last question was age 18.
well look i mean um
all charitable gaming is 18 right now
uh all of uh lottery for the most part
you buy a scratch ticket you could buy a
25 scratch ticket
and be 18. i mean uh
and uh and i can go to i can go to the
brook
and i can place a better aqueduct
simulcast
and be 18 years old and do that so
uh not simulcast racing
so you know we can address
the larger issue of the age of gambling
in the state if you'd like
but i don't want to do it within this
bill this bill isn't working within the
parameters
of what already exists that we've
recognized in this state since the 1930s
that an 18 year old can place a bet on a
horse race
and that's the case today was the case
10 years ago was the case 20 years ago
i'll leave it at that thank you
representative
would you this is to representative
abrami again would you support
uh changing back to a 10 debt limit
and uh and putting in the amendment that
we all
voted for um two years ago regarding
autocad
i'm not because i want to be consistent
with the the senate
uh it's going to be hard enough to pass
this on the floor
as is uh and i i
uh there's a cons there's a similar bill
in the senate
that if we pass it if it does pass the
house
i don't want to have to go through an
amendment process with them and having
to go back to the floor a second time
uh with the bill so
no i'm not willing no i mean you can
play
the amendment if you like uh but i would
i would recommend that we don't vote for
that amendment
okay representative romney you had your
hand up for speaking
well i was just saying can we move the
question
okay um that requires
this i thought this was a working
sentiment yes right
we're not nobody has made a motion
and i have amendments to off i know i
understand
and i appreciate your amendments i i are
we done with the work session i guess
and
uh i'd like to move to executive session
and and vote this bill up or down
we need a vote in order to
move to the world uh the executive
session whose seconds
of romney i do mr chief
representative said we need to take a
vote to move to
uh do i need to take a vote or executive
session
i can i think we've had a lot of
discussion on this you can either
vote yes
from the motion you have to introduce
that
yes mr chairman i'd like to move ought
to pass on hb
626. seconded by
motions ought to pass by representative
dussette
is there any further questions or
comments
on the motion about to pass
mr chairman representative
i mean all me sorry
thank you i i want
to move uh oh dear
the amendment that i sent uh everyone on
local option i'm gonna have to
five four four seven five four four
and i don't think i need to speak to my
emotion
okay representative elmi wants a more
amendment i think it's just four
four seven isn't it no it's five four
seven
eight seconded by
[Music]
our second what was that representative
ames
any further discussion on the amendment
i am my hands up representative
uh yes i appreciate the discussion
really most of my questions were covered
but i just want to say for my city of
dover they really
appreciate being given the local option
thank you okay um further
questions or comments representative
elliot
represent elliott you're muted okay
there's already a motion on the floor
otp and now there's an amendment on the
floor
uh can you have uh which one gets
preference the amendment or the original
motion of
otp we need to take care of the
amendment before we go
any further questions or comments uh
you muted that pat you muted
thank you thank you mr chair i'm going
to respectfully vote no on this
amendment
any further questions or comments on the
your hand is still up representative
rodney oh no that was
yeah that was my comment okay it's
coming down
all right since there's no more
hands up then i'm going to have to call
the roll on the amendment
representative bernstein thank you mr
chair
this is uh amendment 0547h
on house bill 626 let's begin the roll
call vote
with representative abrami no
representative mcdonald no
representative ovary no
over no the clerk votes no
to doucet no elliot
no genigen no nunes
no baxter no
it's pillsbury no tudor
doesn't you muted yes
ames yes southward
yes malloy yes
schamberg representative schamberg votes
yes
tucker
you muted representative tucker
no representative gomarlo
yes representative loftman
is not voting representative gorg
stepped out so she's not voting
representative murphy
mr chair the amendment fails by a vote
of 14
the vote then 14 to 8 the motion details
are there any other motions mr chair
me on i move
amendment 548 h
on and i wish to speak briefly to my
motion
representative moves amendment 548
thank you mr chairman on first
on this amendment asks
puts into law a registry of the
individuals who has to be banned from
their location
and this was
[Music]
mentioned when i asked him by
mr mcintyre on as something
that could be done and i think in this
case
it is extremely important for the
community
and for the people who come to play
to produce the money that goes free to
those charities
on the second part of this would ask for
a report
by november 1st on the procedures to
identify
problem gamers who wager uh
and to contact them offering treatment
information
this is something also that is generally
within the purview
of the lottery enforcement division
and i would ask that at least
this get added on thank you
any further comments on the amendment 5
representative just want to remind
everybody that
in the bill itself there's a provision
that says
each licensee must have a responsible
gaming plan
so that that kind of touches on some of
what
representative romney is is talking
about
so i'm going to be voting no on this
amendment
thank you any further questions or
comments on the amendment
on if i could respond
representative thank you
on the income of these operators depends
on their having people gamble as much in
those machines
as possible on and
that they are solely responsible for
identifying with no oversight
on the people that are gambling as much
as possible
represented
thank you mr chairman i too am
respectfully voting on this uh
as as it stands each charitable gaming
room
uh must submit to uh uh submit a
responsible gaming plan under rsa 284
calling 22
b roman numeral 3-1
any further questions or comments on
mere
amendment 548
saying none i'll ask the clerk to call
the rules
thank you mr chair amendment zero five
four
eight h to hb 626 let's begin the roll
call with representative abrami
no representative mcdonald
no
representative overy no
ober kirk bursting votes no
doucette no elliott no
jenigian no nunez no
baxter no spillsbury
no tudor no
army yes
ames yes southworth
yes malloy yes schamberg
representative schamberg votes yes
tucker
yes go marlo no
loftman representative laughman not
voting
not voting one more time hacking
phillips
mr chair the amendment fails by a vote
of 15
no and seven yes
the vote on amendment 5 4
8 h fails because it the vote was
15 nos and 7 yes so any more amendments
any further discussion on the bill
with a motion about to pass
the chairman of might speak to my motion
briefly
represented this out thank you mr
chairman
the uh you got the pass motion on house
bill 626
um this is not a request to approve a
new form of gaming in our state
it's to take an existing form that has
been legal in the state since
the 1930s and it brings into the 21st
century
brings us into the 21st century by
allowing it to function
electronically a state lottery which has
brought in hundreds of millions of
dollars for education since the first
lottery based power mutual bet was
placed here
in my town at rockingham park in salem
new hampshire on september 14
1964. this bill allows the opportunity
for us to once again
bet on that race for education
and for the charities new hampshire was
the first in the nation to create the
lottery
although historic racing is pro
prevalent in other states let new
hampshire lead the way to utilize it
for the benefit of charities in the
state and
education through this adaptive reuse of
power mutual
wagering in new hampshire thank you mr
chair
thank you repton to set any other
comments
saying none i'll ask the clerk to call
them
a vote on ought to pass on house bill
626-fm
thank you mr chair let's begin the roll
call vote with representative abrami
yes representative mcdonald
yes owen
yes ober yes
clerk berstein votes yes doucet
step down so no vote
nunes yes
baxter yes spillsbury
no aims
oh southworth no
malloy no schamberg
representative schamberg votes yes
tucker yes
representative hacken phillips is not
voting representative murphy
mr chair the motion of ought to pass
carries by a vote of 16 yes five no
votes
the vote being 16 yes and five no
the motion of did i ask how that
house bill 626 pilot
[Music]
what i want to do now is to go to house
bill
15.
this
house bill 15-fm relative to encoding
under the meals and rooms tax
facilitators
of internet transactions of motor
vehicle rentals
and facilitators of internet
transactions of room occupancy
representative romney makes a motion of
otp
representative
hold on one second
okay do i
hear any discussion or emotions
for amendments on house bill 15
yeah can i ask you a question for
discussion first
representative baxter thank you mr
chair um there's still an issue
myself i've mentioned it and multiple
members have the concern of whether
this will create a new tax on
travel agent services and
that's why i proposed an amendment to
try to alleviate
that concern i know there's some concern
about the language of the amendment
but there's been no proposed solution
that
our caucus or the committee has come to
to deal with that concern so i think
we need to um alleviate that concern
before passing the bill
that's why i asked
the dra the present
so that we could have that discussion
we can have that discussion either
through a motion for an amendment or
just plain go to that discussion
and uh that has been a concern so
um representative gemaldo if you would
allow
a second uh
is he a panelist i just promoted her
thank you
[Applause]
now looking at the discussion
on
whether this is a new tax or not and
also the discussion on
agent
so i'm open up
any any questions from the committee
we have the dra to be able to answer so
representatives
boxer
yeah thank you mr chair i'm not sure if
the the representative from the dra
heard
um what i just said a few minutes ago
about the concern about
uh this being a new tax on travel agent
services so if they can speak to that i
carolyn lear who is the deputy
commissioner
from the dra could you uh speak to that
of course representative thank you
carolyn lear assistant commissioner at
the department of revenue
um i think what's difficult about this
question
um is that as we've sort of considered
this
issue over several legislative sessions
um
we've not ever heard from travel agents
um so i had to do a bit of baseline
research to answer this question
and what i've sort of found through my
own research is that travel agents
typically are compensated with a
commission
paid from the hotel for example
directly to the travel agent and
the m r tax is paid as a percentage
of the total price paid by the consumer
so in these what i understand to be the
typical
travel agent transactions the commission
would not be subject to tax
because it's paid by the hotel to the
travel agent
not by the consumer to the travel agent
um
and specifically i would look to line 16
of the bill which makes very clear that
it's paid by the
occupant if hb 15
is passed as is we can certainly when we
um undertake the rule making process for
this bill
really flush that out in rules um
i think as i discussed with
representative major yesterday are
concerned with the amendment is whether
it's
a bit of um a blanket exemption
if someone uses the term quote unquote
travel agent
without sort of substantively sussing
out what that term
means and do we then sort of let someone
say i'm a travel agent and therefore
i'm carte blanc not obligated to collect
um so i understand the concern
absolutely with making sure
travel agents are not unintentionally
looped in
i do think we can handle that issue in
in rules well why not just
amend or change the language slightly of
my amendment
or someone else could propose an
amendment
essentially saying this that travel
agent services won't be taxed but you
can't
add a component of your business that's
a travel state service agency
to exempt the entirety of your
businesses
i feel like that's it's fairly simple
the issue is if we don't have the
amendment in there
they're still looking the original
concern which hasn't been dealt with yet
and i and i respect what you're saying
that it could be worked out but i feel
like
it's a better approach to work it out
before
we ought to pass the bill then to leave
so certainly um that would be
i don't i don't have a position on that
i think that would be a workable
solution as well to deal with it in the
bill
um i would still say that i do
think we need we would still need to in
rules
substantively define what the term
travel agent
means um so that you can't just you know
call yourself a travel agent and
therefore you are one we need to sort of
define that term to distinguish a travel
agent
from a platform for example um
but i could we could certainly um do
that in rules as well
yeah yeah and i guess that's kind of
what i'm getting to is
the amen it's not necessarily the the
amendment that's issues just making sure
and
rules that the amendment is clarified to
not
allow people to call themselves a travel
agent when they're not
but as long as that's worked out and
rules then would you say the amendment
i guess he's asking do we need to do we
need the amendment
well what i'm asking you is as long as
rules makes it clear that you can't just
call yourself a travel agent when you're
not
then wouldn't the amendment work as
intended
to make sure that travel agents aren't
being taxed
which isn't the intent of anyone that
created this bill
without creating a new loophole just
make sure that's clear in rules that you
can't just
so i'm i'm comfortable um
in saying that the um the definition of
travel agent
would fall within our rulemaking
authority
i think the question i have based on the
language
of the amendment is whether the
amendment
language is clear enough that an
operator who has for example
one percent of their line of business
being a travel agent business
and the other 99 attributable to
something where they would be
responsible for collecting and remitting
the tax
that the one percent doesn't affect the
and is it is it your belief that
through the the rules process that we
couldn't make it clear that the 99
is being taxed as is the case now and
i fear that the amendment as written
could be interpreted to scoop in the 99
because it says the term shall not apply
to the services of a person formed firm
corporation or
partnership providing travel agent
services
but doesn't limit that phrase
to the portion of their business that
constitutes
being a travel agent i i
i hear what i hear what you're saying
about that fear and i guess what i'm
really trying to hammer down
is do not think that fear can be
eliminated through the rules process i
want to get a clear answer on your
perspective on that
i'm worried that um that the rule making
committee that reviews our rules
will say that we're acting outside of
our rule-making authority or
in contradiction to what the statute
says
okay so i guess you're and you can
correct me if i'm not understanding you
correctly but you're not sure what would
happen how
how the rules process would work out
based off how the amendment is currently
written is that correct
that's correct thank you i
mr chair i'd like to make a motion at
this point
we didn't we didn't discuss this in
caucus
there's still a lot of um uncertainty
at this point i think we should we
should work on the amendment language
before
ought to passing this bill this bill
further
and if anything i would make a motion
i'm not saying i'm making a motion right
now but if anything it should be
retained before we pass this
with all the uncertainty about my
amendment language and with the travel
agent component and i'm not the only
member on the committee that feels this
i think we can continue discussing this
bill
from what i hear the uh
first representative from the dra saying
is that
the bill is passed as is not the
amendment
they could take care of this issue
and then so
it's up to the committee whether they
want to proceed
with i guess mr or go ahead mr chair i
don't want to cut you off if you want to
i i guess the where
what the concern is for me is we're
hearing well we can deal with the issue
without amending it
in rules but we think in rules that if
we do amend it we can't
we can't change the amendment so it's
kind of like which one is it you know
i would rather if the rules issues may
be a process i'd rather just
wait and make sure we do it right the
first time
as a committee before sending it sending
it over to rules
without it being a hundred percent
certain
we're gonna get the outcome we're
and there's we need to
answer a question do we get this over to
the senate
they can deal with that issue if
we find that we come up with a solution
at this point the solution is is the
whether we have confidence in the dra
and what they told us that they can
handle that
and uh i think the committee needs to
make up their mind on that
so why don't we hear from some of the
committee members
thank you mr chair uh i was out i would
like to ask tra
to elaborate a little bit on the
court decision and the restrictions that
placed
upon their uh tax collecting ability
uh that was referenced in their letter
could could they do that
sir
thank you for the question
representative i'm happy
to discuss that briefly um
so as you all
know because you've followed the case
throughout the last
several years
as these online room sharing
specifically
platforms became
more prominent in the room rental and
hotel rental
market new hampshire along with every
other state
attempted to assert that the m r tax
requires the platform
to collect and remit the m r tax
on behalf of the various properties that
that case in new hampshire went all the
way
to the new hampshire supreme court
and they said that excuse me
our statute which was you know drafted
at a time when
these weren't um or this wasn't a
prominent method
prominent method of renting rooms didn't
capture
those um platforms as operators
and i think it's important to understand
why the state would want to take the
position
that the platform and not the individual
is the operator um so
under the m r tax statute you know every
person who owns a vacation home
or rents out an in-law suite on a
temporary basis
is required to become licensed and
submit
monthly returns to the state of new
hampshire
and collect the m r tax on those
transactions that's the case even if
someone
only rents their room for one night out
of the year
they're required to become licensed and
collect and remit the m
r tax so as a
sort of administrative convenience for
us
as well as the individual operators
we do think that it's certainly a more
efficient
method of tax collection for us to
license
and expect the platforms to collect
rather than each individual home
owner it results in you know thousands
of less m r tax returns
each month um were we to
audit we would audit the platform
rather than each individual property
owner and
because the platform is actually
the entity that assesses the tax
and collects the money from the consumer
we actually
think it's the platform who's properly
responsible
for that collection and remission and
audit
does that answer your question
representative
i'm not entirely
in the question that was raised by
representative baxter
if you wanted to make sure that this was
not a new tax
and that the clarification as to who was
going to pay the tax
does that court ruling apply to the
questions that the representative baxter
raised
um not directly um
i could look back and
get you any comments that the court made
on the issue
of um fees generally
but the court never really had to get to
that question
um because they ended their their
analysis really at the
at the level of the operator is not
um the platform is not an operator um
and that sort of ends the inquiry um
but i could look back and see if there's
any what i would call dicta
about the um the fee portion
um but i think in this instance i think
the statute is very
clear that the the tax applies to the
amount of money paid by the consumer
to rent the room so as
to the the travel agent question
so long as we're talking about sort of
the typical transaction as i understand
it
the travel agent's fee which generally
is not
paid by the consumer is never going to
be captured by the m r tax
which is why i'm sort of comfortable
saying we can deal with that issue
in rule um i think it becomes
murkier simply because of the
uh uh thank you uh miss claire the uh
from what you just said it seems as
though
dra is very clear that this doesn't
apply to the agent
in any case because of the
wording in the existing law
and the restrictions that were placed on
the agency's tax collection ability
by the decision in a broad sense not in
a narrow sense but in a broad sense
applying it to the individual paying the
tax
have i got that more or less correct
yes representative you i believe you
have that correctly
thank you ma'am thank you mr chair thank
you
for the question that was very
enlightening
uh representative
thank you mr chairman i think that there
is
a difficulty in that
many members actually not just new
members
don't understand the on
jail car process and the fact that if
their attorneys feel that on
something is that is put forward by the
agency does not
represent the intent of the legislators
on they on impose
fairly heavy sanctions that we put in
place because agencies were
getting out of control about 20 years
ago so
on i think that we really should solve
this ourselves rather than go back uh
let it go to the senate and have the
same argument
i that and i think that it ought to be
fairly easy to put an amendment in
that was fashioned between
the dra and
[Music]
representative baxter on that says
that this does not apply to on
services provided on
as a travel agent which on
are not on the rentals
of rooms
on or cars and
and then leave it to the dra
in rules to specify okay this is a
travel
agent service
on something of that nature and that we
ought that ought to be able to be
produced by tomorrow
in my opinion thank you okay
thank you um so i've been in the
hospitality industry for 30 years
and um i have an example that might be
helpful so back in the day when starwood
was a hotel brand before it became a
marriott
they we used to have a program where
anyone could get
money back on a particular event it was
built into the contract
and at one point it actually was changed
so only real estate agent i've never
really seen apologize travel agents
could get
that particular it's not a kickback but
it is an extra
bonus to them to book at a particular
hotel
um and the way that we did it was that
the travel agent had to provide their
um travel there's a travel agent network
um
it's an international airline travel
network it's
iatan and they also have an american
society for travel agents
a s t a um
we require them to put their membership
number in there and that kind
of bypassed it made them legitimate
travel agents right for so those who had
that as a business
um are part of these membership
organizations
and i don't know if that's helpful to
representative baxter or if it'd be
helpful to
dra but that might be a way to help
um clarify in rules or in any amendment
so i just wanted to add there this is
common in the hospitality industry
and that's kind of how they get around
this
okay representative of romney
all i can say is wow um
i'm ready to vote on this the way it is
but i'll respect
others that still have or that are
uncomfortable
uh and feel that we need an amendment
as long as someone's willing to put the
energy in to get the amendment going
i think we can handle the whole issue
and rules i
i don't see a big deal here
but if someone wants to take another
crack at an amendment
let's let's go do it uh
and as representative romney said we
could probably take this up tomorrow but
uh you know representative baxter you
did take
you took a crack at an amendment it
sounds like that amendment still needs
work
uh if you're willing to take another
crack at that amendment
um that's fine with me
uh but there's gonna be a point at which
we're gonna run out of time here
[Music]
understanding this was the house
position last term
uh meaning the ways and means position i
should say that was the ways of means
position
of the members that were present then
we spent a lot of time on this i think
representative malloy had the
subcommittee on it
i was a member of it and we spent a lot
of time with the era on it
and we pretty much went around around
and we we
put together what we thought was pretty
good legislation so again i don't want
to be the one saying
you know whatever if it sounds like
there's still some folks who want to see
an
amendment i'm okay with that i'm not
going to be the one to do it
but uh but if we're going to do it we
got to do it
uh soon thank you
okay representative southwood uh thank
you mr chairman
um i agree mostly with representative
abrami
um i have the confidence in
dra's rule-making procedures
to me this bill is about fairness and
again
i was around before when a lot of work
went into the bill
my only variance from um representative
abrami is i really don't think an
amendment is necessary
and i would hope um
we wouldn't have to spend extra time on
an amendment if it really
isn't really necessary so i'd be ready
for otp today
thank you representative
spillsberg thank you mr chairman yeah
i'd like to just go on record now is
saying i think the bill
addresses the matter adequately
uh with all respect i do think that the
amendment monies the water
i don't think an amendment is necessary
i think the rule making that
uh process will deal with any
clarifications
and basically the bill i think everyone
agrees
addresses the consequences of the
litigation dealing with online platforms
in the context of rental facilitators
the question
of whether travel agent
services somehow represents a new tax
i think again can be dealt with
administratively it's clear to me that
the bill does not
and very simply it's taxing everything
that the consumer
is required to pay for the purposes of
a room or a car
i think the skinny lift ticket package
things already been
dealt with um so it really comes down to
travel agent commissions and the fact is
that those are done differently by
different
organizations airbnb they do it one way
booking.com they do it another way
it still comes down what does the
consumer have to pay
to book the room or the parent and
it doesn't make a difference whether the
consumer pays the entire fee
to the booking agent who keeps his
commission and turns the rest
over to the hotel
for second whether he pays
nothing to the booking agent which is
true at booking.com
and then pays on arrival and then
the hotel pays a commission separately
which is just a marketing expense or
third whether he pays the commission
to the booker and separately all three
of these i have seen an experience
the outcome's the same in every case the
total that the consumer pays
is subject to the from the meals tax and
i think the only thing that that boils
down to that
representative baxter is actually asking
is also clear and that is
if the consumer has paid the entire
amount
and the amount includes whatever the
lodging
facilities expenses are then there is no
question
when the lodging facility sends a
payment to the booking agent
for their services that
is already been in the amount that the
consumer paid
it's already been subject to the meals
and rooms tax and we are not
proposing in this bill to double tax
the transaction that simply transmits
the commission
so i i'm sorry to go on that i just i
sat here
listening to the entire discussion in
recent sessions and i think
it's there's not a problem here that we
need to deal with
i'm ready to vote representative elliot
thank you mr chairman um this
bill on the 27th of january
was contested for over an
hour and at that point
madame carolyn lear stated that
litigation in every state
has been passed on this type of bill so
it's obviously
controversial i would hope that
representative baxter might want to
complete a clarification
amendment and present it to the
committee tomorrow when we
meet if that's okay with him but
right now i i think that this bill even
though if we passed it which i'm going
to
vote yes um is going to fail again
so thank you mr chairman thank you
representative you mr chair
and i had some initial concerns with
this but after listening to uh
the uh dra i think i'm comfortable with
representative nunes
thank you mr chairman um i'm tending to
lead to the side where i think that we
might need to work on this methodology a
little bit more
in statute before it gets handed over to
dra to make a rule
i didn't get a warm and fuzzy feeling uh
from the commissioner
no no no disrespect there but i didn't
get the warm and fuzzy feeling that
that the rules committee for the dra
was going to be in favor of a rule that
would be adopted by her to take care of
the
to take care of the situation that we're
talking about in methodology
on top of these travel agents uh if
representative baxter could be given an
opportunity to clarify that amendment
i think it would actually help the dra
make a better rule
and that's where i stand on that okay
let me ask
representative baxter
if you think you could work with the dre
come up with an amendment for tomorrow
yeah absolutely i'm happy to do that and
i appreciate
all the fellow members um representative
almi as well
that have suggested that i'm more than
happy to do that
then uh i've got one more hand
represented elmer thank you
i just wanted to point out that we did
work on this
for three four years and i don't think
it
failed on the floor we just kept
studying it
and we were waiting for wayfair to
finish
uh in order to pass it because it would
have been a little hypocritical
before on but on
this is something that on
that depends a lot on the details of the
language
so i hope that our representative baxter
and ms lear will communicate
on with each other about the
difficulties of the language versus what
representative baxter wants to do i'm
going to ask
representative abrami
and represent elmi to withdraw the
motion
and we'll deal with this tomorrow
i'll withdraw my second i would point
out we could do this on the
is here
[Music]
mr chairman there's a lot of internet
issues today people keep popping in and
out i'm watching in gallery view and
[Music]
okay that was uh representative romney
his power just went out his generator
come on
and so he's probably taking a little
while to come back on
but i asked him if he would draw his
motion and he's
in order to be able to have
representative baxter
work with cowling to come up with a new
amendment for tomorrow and he agrees
so if that's the case anything else we
want to talk about
if not uh i recommend that we take
a five to eight minute break
don't turn the video or your audio off
uh
just mute them and then we'll be back in
you
five
representative model yes
as pat rejoined us
i have not seen him yet
there's a telephone number oh maybe
that's him
i would say it is brad must have left
him
that that is his number mr chair oh
thank you
can can he hear us and speak because he
uh star six for unmute but it looks like
you're unmuted anyways
oh now you're muted yeah that is
doesn't doesn't sound like he can
yep
mr chairman yes representative
you didn't ask about the minority report
for
hp 626 but i think representative ames
was willing to do it
that'll be fine and when he
when representative ames has it
completed if he sends it
you know it's hard to keep track of the
it seems to me it's not not a big hurry
because uh
there's no sessions scheduled i think i
i we heard that uh there might be a
couple of days
at the end of this month yeah at the
end of this month but there's uncertain
i would say if you get it uh
now i'd like to know how you're active
on this
there's no car right now if you're
and uh representative abrami we still
haven't
heard you yet so i'm i'm nervous that
you can't
represent romney if you could hear us
isn't star nine to put your hand up i
think star six
is to speak patricia
six
and it looks like we added
representative lachmann um
alan for your attendance uh thank you
representative southworth
i'm on it i know that he was here thank
you
yeah so representative abram it looks
like you muted yourself when you did
that
i think star 9 was your hand as well or
do i have to do it
huh that's not good
you know i didn't have internet this
morning and i came on initially
with my phone but it was via the zoom
app i itself
know if you can quickly download that
and
and i even had video use my camera
somehow
so
yeah brad could you give representative
romney
a hand on that yep if he um he may need
to
log out of the meeting log back and call
back in again
sometimes it just doesn't connect right
away so who may just need to
well
because nothing turns out to be easy
i'd like to continue with house bill
210-fn
increasing the exemption under the
interest and dividend tax and decreasing
the total amount of research development
credit against the business taxes
uh
i i didn't but i believe we should
probably hold this bill
until we have a better understanding of
the uh
uh and the governor are you talking
about the same bill is that 210 or 10
210 210. i'm sorry i thought we were
yes i i would like to make a motion to
retain this bill
okay tonight do we have a second
they both show on february 24th
okay representative spellsbury do you
want to
speak to your motion well yes very
briefly
um obviously hp
uh 210
and uh 568
overlapped with two different approaches
uh
i don't think we've given enough
consideration to
the implications of the rnd and tying
them versus going
separately and i think it requires
further attention
any further discussion from the
representative bernstein to call the
vote
on house bill 210 thank you mr chair
the motion is to retain hb 210
let's begin the voting with
representative
rami uh who's that they will come back
to him how about representative mcdonald
let's begin the roll call vote with
representative mcdonald
clerk votes yes representative doucet
yes thank you sir representative
genigean
baxter yes spillsberry
yes tudor yes army
yes
yes southward
yes malloy yes
schamberg represent schamberg votes yes
tucker yes go marlow
yes laughman
yes gorg yes
murphy yes chairman of uh
they retain motion correct yes
chairman major yes
mr chair the vote is 23 yes
the vote then 23-1 the motion of retain
we will go to house bill 252
i've moved to retain sir and i'd like to
second okay we have
representative moves to retain seconded
by representative
is that 252
house bill 252. thank you that's
creating a committee to
study the creation program giving an
employee tax credit
on business taxes in exchange for
providing stipends for
child care needs to employees
yeah i show that they're in australia
mr chair there's additional work that
needs to be done on this to see the
ramifications that are involved
it needs some additional research and as
such it deserves to be retained so it
can undertake that
work thank you any further discussion
i don't see any hands raised so click
call thank you mr chair let's begin the
roll call vote on the motion to retain
house bill 252 we'll begin with
representative abrami
yes representative mcdonald
yes owerry uh
yes ober yes clerk votes yes
representative ellen yes thank you
janine yes nunes
yes baxter yes
pillsbury yes tudor
yes army yes ames
yes southworth yes
malloy yes schamberg
representative schamberg vote yes tucker
yes
go marlow yes laughman
yes gorg yes hacken phillips
yes murphy yes chairman major
yes mr chair the motion to retain
carries 24 to nothing the vote been 24
and up
we'll go to a house bill 554-local
could you repeat that number i don't
have it
it's house bill 504 dash
fn dash local an act relative to the
state education
property tax and the low and moderate
income homeowners property tax
relief program uh
representative spillsbury yes thank you
mr chairman i'd like to make a motion
that we retain this bill for further
study
it's a very complicated bill and uh has
implications for communities that i
don't think have been fully discussed
yet
i'll give a second that representative
ames
thanks
motion on house bill 504
is to retain by representative
spellsbury
seconded by representative ames
any further discussion on 504.
seeing none i'll ask the cliff to call
the role
on motion to retain thank you mr
chair um let's begin the voting on hb
with representative abrami yes yes
representative mcdonald yes overy
yes ober yes first gene the clerk votes
yes
ducette yes elliot
yes genigean yes nunes
yes baxter yes nosebury
yes tudor yes army
i'm going to put representative
southworth down as not voting
representative malui yes uh yes sorry
about that
i was muted no problem thank you
southworth votes yes malloy voted yes
representative schamberg
yes tucker yes go marlow
yes laughman yes gorg
yes hacking phillips yes murphy
yes chairman major yes
mr chair the motion to retain hb 504
passes 24 to nothing
the vote been 24 or nothing on retaining
we'll go to house bill 568
dash fn a
enact increasing exemptions of the
interest and dividend tax and repealing
the tax
representative bromley make a motion to
retain
representative romney makes the motion
share the the clerk will second that
bursting
representative bursting second the
motion to return
any discussion on the motion to retain
on house bill
any discussion on house bill 568
seen no hands raised so if the clerk
called
the role on the motion to retain on 568.
thank you mr chair let's begin the
voting with representative obrami
yes mcdonald yes hillary
yes ober yes bursting votes yes you said
there's somebody talking in the
background
representative
thank you representative baxter yes
i think he might be frozen too uh we'll
come back to representative tudor
let's proceed to representative almi
yes i think representative tudor has
been being represented by
by a video a non-video
representative tudor are you back online
i think so
my vote is yes thank you sir
southward
we'll come back representative malloy
yes
chamber representative schamberg votes
tucker yes go marlow yes
laughman yes gorg yes
hacking phillips murphy
yes representative southworth are you
back with us
i'm going to put representative
southwest is not voting here he is
oh you got him just under the gun uh
representative
uh chairman major yes
mr chair the motion to retain hb
568 passes 24 to nothing
as a reminder i noticed technical
difficulties today but
people have to be on video to take in a
vote
yeah representative self-worth has not
yes now i think that was also
true of another representative
um okay no we should be but it has been
true of several people
but i agree we should be seen you're
going to have to sit
out because i'm trying to write at the
i'll watch it okay representative major
i'll watch for that
thank you i i believe representative
tudor has been showing a picture
not himself he's it's been him
it hasn't moved well maybe he's frozen
he's he's got horrible connections but
he's got a problem
just a really slow connection he has oh
god
okay 24-0
the motion to retain passes on house
bill
now we have two bills left on the in the
dra group that's house bill
10 house bill 15 and we'll talk about
those tomorrow
which i guess we're gonna have a loud
and player vote on this thing
the first is cacr one
uh relating to taxes
providing that an income tax on earned
personal income
and
wrapped
who wants to make a motion yeah
representative abrami makes a motion on
uh
otp on cacr1
[Music]
representative romney makes a motion of
otp
the motion is ought to pass by
represented by
romney second by representative
so speak on your motion representative
bromley
real quick my position is let the people
speak
any further questions on cacr1 uh
representative yeah i have a comment
represented ames yeah just uh
to say that i will be voting against
this and uh
i believe that the existing provisions
in the constitution provide
clear and appropriate guidance to all
questions of taxation
they've worked well with some
modifications over the years
for the last two plus centuries and
i see no uh reason to
intrude on um that um
that set of provisions i'd also note
that
a prohibition on one
objective taxation earned personal
income
[Music]
raises questions as to its scope we have
tax we have attacks right now
business proper business profits tax
that applies to sole proprietors
we also have a business enterprise tax
that
that targets
salaries as a core part of the formula
and so there's ambiguities as well so i
i think this
proposal is not ready and should not be
put forward to the general population
as a constitutional amendment
any further discussion on cacr1
any further discussion on cacry1 and
sandman
i'll ask the clerk to call the role
i'm also about to pass
thank you mr chair
let's begin the roll call vote for the
otp motion on
cacr1 we'll begin with representative
abrami
yes representative mcdonald yes
ore yes ober
yes the clerk bursting votes yes doucet
yes elliot yes
genigean yes nunes
yes baxter yes sillsberry
yes tudor yes
army no
ames no southworth
representative malloy please turn on
i think i got a call yeah
okay i'm gonna put we'll come back to
malloy before i put him down into nova
representative schamberg
representative schamberg votes no tucker
no murphy no
representative dennis malloy i'm gonna
put down as a no as
not voting chairman major
yes mr chair the motion of ought to pass
out of committee all we need is a
cacr yes that's correct okay
then the vote being 13 to 10
mr chair it might be
helpful to make
clear what the rule will be on the floor
it's a majority coming out of the
committee
um but maybe you could inform the
committee of what happens on the floor
on the floor it takes i believe 60
percent
to pass on the floor 60 percent
of the i
think it's the full house
that was present just those president
uh don't quote me on that yeah i was
gonna look it up i
didn't get around to it so i'm not
actually sure sixty percent
anyway but it could be the present or
the house and
the way we're split i don't think it's
going to pass
we're just going to do a pi we're only
going to do a pi on our side
yeah there's not going to be a speech on
our side i'll do a pi on
the other side okay well you know i
can't speak for
the general population who knows who
might speak up but uh
that would be the plan yeah as we get it
done quick
thank you is there going to be a
minority report
yes okay so there'll be a majority and a
minority report and hopefully there's
just
pis on the floor yeah and i'll do the
pis i mean the
excuse me the reports the report
all right ca62
almost like cacr1 but
it's relating to taxes providing that
any broad-based sales tax should be
prohibited
representative bernstein thank you mr
chair
i'd like to move otp on cacr2
and seconded by i will second that mr
chair
the motion pass has been made
by representative bernstein seconded by
representative bernstein you know
say anything sure just very briefly um
similar to the last vote this
simply affords the people an opportunity
to vote
so by casting a yes vote and supporting
the motion
to pass this this you're not
prohibiting attacks all you're doing is
giving the people a chance
to speak um therefore i i
i will be voting yes on this bill
representative
yes uh thank you and ditto uh
on the uh sufficiency of the existing
constitutional provisions
to what i said uh on the previous cacr
and uh also ditto to the ambiguity and
the
targeted source of uh
income or the target that would uh be
prohibited
uh which this this prohibition would uh
preclude from taxation
um where a broad-based sales tax in this
case
is a term that different people have
defined differently in different
settings the tax foundation in
particular has
identified a sales tax that has
significant
exemptions from products that are not
subject to it
um as not broad-based so what is what
isn't
i don't know um but uh
those are my two uh points with regard
to
this proposal
representative
thank you i just wanted to point out we
have a long history in this state of not
legislating by referendum uh
which i mean just look at california
what a mess
made of itself by doing that and these
two proposals would both uh
if they were passed by the population
on make it almost certain that it's some
future date in our state
our state would be up against a wall so
badly
that we would end up either with anarchy
or we would end up
on with a
major resolution revolution of some kind
so we we don't know what the economy is
going to look like in the future we
don't know what
what can be taxed in order to pay for
the government
of this state on and
there is no way we can know what's going
to happen
50 years from now 100 years from now
thank you thank you representative may
anybody else
want to make a comment on the motion of
what to pass
on cacr2
i see no hands up so i'll ask the clerk
to call the role
on out to pass on caacr2
thank you mr chair let's begin the roll
call vote on cacr2
the motion is ought to pass
representative patrick abrami
yes representative mcdonald yes
representative hollery yes
representative ober yes the clerk votes
yes
representative doucette yes
elliot yes genigean yes
nunes yes baxter
yes billsbury yes tudor
yes army
no ames no
no
representative tucker no go marlow
laughman gorg
no hacken phillips no murphy
no chairman major yes
mr chair the motion of ought to pass
the motion about to pass on cacr2
calendar
and remember just the pi on this thing
listen
okay the next is already report
number minority report yeah i'm gonna
i'm gonna do that uh
and again i think by monday is that
right representative major
yes that'd be fine the next bill
346. hold on a second i have to get the
an act relative to the funding source
fund
me mr chairman what was that what was
that again
house bill 346 relative to the funding
source for domestic violence program
i need a motion for that
representative brummie here i'll um
barbie wants to itl this uh but i guess
we'll retain it
so motion to retain he makes a motion to
retain
house bill 346. second representative
and he just you want to speak to the
emotion representative
of romney well uh he
uh representative edwards came in with a
bill but then he also came in with an
amendment
the amendment basically took the money
from domestic violence funds and put it
into the general fund
and then he was going to turn around and
somehow
fund domestic violence
uh because he's one of the chairs of the
of finance and i'm sitting here going
wow that's all nice but
uh then you don't need this build
uh if you think you can do it all your
own
go ahead and besides the point
is that we'd still have to even if we
passed something
would have to go to the senate and
and by that point the budget would have
been done and this is all moot so
uh again my brother's just to itl it but
i'm retaining it
just to uh to minimize the amount of uh
of uh bills that we have to deal with on
the floor
okay representative thank you mr
chairman
on is it my understanding that
if we retain it and uh it is not
otherwise solved that on
representative edwards had said that he
was going to come back
next year if we passed this and
with a permanent funding source which
his solution
is not um it is only for this term
if it passed the senate and the governor
on so um would we
be retaining it in order to listen to
his next suggestion
in the fall i would say yes but
i'm not i'm not hopeful we're going to
hear something that
we could act on but you know it could be
but uh um we're just retaining it
just so that to be honest with you we're
retaining it
so that we don't have to deal with it as
a full bod a full house
uh in the next session
because we we're trying to minimize the
number of bills we have to deal with
on the floor any further discussion
uh representative sellsworth uh thank
you mr chairman
although i support idl itl sorry
i think this is a good compromise and um
really we don't need to rush it this
year
thank you any further discussion on
house bill 346.
see and then i'm going to ask the clerk
to call the vote on house bill 346
which the motion is to retain thank you
mr chair
let's begin the roll call vote on hb 346
with representative abrami
yes representative mcdonald
yes yes
ober yes first jean the clerk votes yes
dousette yes elliot
yes genigean yes nunes
yes baxter yes pillsbury
yes tudor yes army
yes ames yes southward
yes malloy yes chamber
yes tucker yes
yes laughman yes
gorg yes hacking phillips
yes murphy yes chairman major
yes mr chair the retained motion
passes 24 to nothing
or voted 24 and often on the motion to
retain what passes
next is house bill 400 and act
relative to the collection of sales tax
taxes of foreign jurisdiction by new
hampshire businesses
representative tudor
representative tudor makes a motion to
but some terror makes the motion retain
on house bill 400 second goodbye
speak to your motion thank you mr chair
hb 400 needs additional work to find out
whether anyone has actually registered
with the state
to um collect this tax so we'd like to
delay it so that we can get the aj in
thank you representative ames
yeah thank you well i'll vote for retain
but
uh i must say that it doesn't seem
necessary to retain this bill when it's
clearly
[Music]
not needed and i i would think it would
be better to dispose of it but
yes we can all learn from information
provided by the attorney general's
office on what's happening
and so i see that as a positive i'll be
voting for retention
thank you uh representative
you mr chair i also will vote for
retain because we have new members who
haven't been through what we went
through last term
however we know that it is extremely
difficult to get the attorney general's
office to show
up on to talk with us on
we had the governor's legal counsel last
time
i'm not sure whether he still is the
governor's legal counsel i haven't heard
his name for quite a while
um and it was his job to be a real
liaison
but on there is um
the attorney general's office itself has
always been difficult
sometimes totally outside their own
control because they had court cases
when we wanted them to show up so i do
hope
that on we can get
somebody i'm not sure who the governor's
legal counsel
is now but maybe it would be useful to
try to go after that person too if it's
for mello that would be terrific
thank you and i i do have a contact
over there and i plan on bringing them
a representative brandi
i just wanted to comment that
representative ames i i
i agree with you 100 uh
i have my brothers i just i tal this as
well
uh we spent a lot of time on this on
this issue
we've we've built a nice fence around
the issue
uh and it seems to be holding
although we're hearing some rumblings of
some people
uh some states trying to start
collecting but
minimal stories minimal uh so
uh then but retaining it it gives us a
vehicle
to study it uh i think we need to
address the issue
we haven't it's been a couple of years
now so we might as well
let's study it let's study where we're
at
what's going on with the ag i know the
department of revenue is also interested
in being involved in this as well
um i don't
see any so i'm going to ask the clerk to
call the vote
on house bill 400.
thank you mr chair let's begin the roll
call vote on hb 400.
the motion is to retain representative
abrami
yes yes mcdonald
yes hillary yes ober
yes bursting votes yes doucet
yes elliott yes genigean
yes nunes yes
baxter yes spillsbury
yes tudor army
yes ames yes southworth
yes malloy yes jamberg
representative schamberg votes yes
tucker
murphy yes chairman major
yes mr chair of the motion carries 24 to
nothing
for the vote being 24 or nothing on
retaining
621-fn an act
allowing registered deeds to retain a
portion of the land and community
heritage
for representation
yes thank you mr chairman i'd like to
make a motion to retain
and representative schamberg like to
the most routines have been made by
representatives
seconded
yes i we heard
some testimony on this bill
i think we still need to study this
further there there's
concern about taking ten percent um
out of the current um l-ship
and um you know i we just need to study
this further to make sure that we
understand the implications that can
any further discussion on house bills
representative bond it could also be
stated that there are many counties that
are actually making
good faith efforts at doing their
restoration including rockingham county
rockingham spends 90 000 on the
restoration of records every year
it spends another 60 000 on the
restoration of their cd-roms
so uh you know most most
registrars of deed are a profit center
for most counties uh they do generate
revenues and there should be money there
to restore the records
any further uh representative elni
thank you mr chairman on i have heard
from the registers of deeds that on
the only county which is not doing what
they are mandated to do in the statutes
to
repair their records is carroll county
which is the one behind this bill
on and in fact one county
coast has been
does not get enough money out of the
registered deeds but is still
appropriating money
from other sources to pay for
preserving their records so i think that
we ought to
take a look at what is happening with
the funding source that
was specified in in our statutes
and how it's being used in the different
counties thank you
thank you representative uh
anybody else wish to comment on
house bill 621
retaining i don't see it
house bill 621 a motion to retain
thank you mr chair let's begin the roll
call vote on hb
621 with representative abrami yes
mcdonald yes bullary yes
over yes bursting votes yes to set
yes elliot yes tunisian
yes
nunes yes baxter
yes spillsbury yes tudor
yes army yes ames
yes southworth yes malui
yes shamburg representative schamberg
votes yes
tucker yes go marlow yes
laughman yes gorg
yes hacking phillips yes murphy
yes chairman major yes
mr chair the motion to retain hb
621 carries 24 to nothing
for the vote 24 or nothing on motion to
retain
the only ones that we have to
address tomorrow is house bill 10
and house bill 15. and on house bill 15
representative baxter will work with the
dra
to come up with an amendment to clarify
that
and then we'll do a regular work session
on house bill 10
tomorrow so we have those two bills
to attend to tomorrow
we made good progress so
bill you know there's a number of bills
that we retain
that probably should have been itl
but every bill that goes to the floor
for itl
and uh you know what happened this past
session there's 35 bills we didn't get
to
so i think personally
i think we made the right decision on
how to handle these things
uh anything else
then if not we're through
for the rest of the day and we'll be
back tomorrow
morning at nine o'clock to deal with
house bill 10 and house bill 15.
i want to remind you that
i sent out an email
that a request from the
finance committee represented weiler and
represented over
and it identifies those parts of hb2
that will affect the revenues
they've been identified so once
hb2 available it should be available
online
you need to take a look at that because
when we meet on the 10th
i want to go over all these because
actually i'd like like to get some
feedback
to the finance committee prior to that
if i could
to help them do their job
and then we have five bills that were
the second committee
on which we'll deal with on the 10th
of this month
am i right in thinking that hb2 has not
shown up yet
it hadn't as of late yesterday afternoon
i haven't checked it this morning
obviously haven't had much time
yeah okay i didn't know how to read that
note
uh representative tucker did you say
something yeah i don't think i
understood that note that i got maybe
you could send it again
or for some reason it
didn't i didn't have a clue what it
meant
well i i will give you a call
representative tucker and go over it
with you
okay essentially on house bill 2
is 169 pages
and then the finance committee
identified
those items in those pages
that they would want input from the ways
and means
committee so if we take
that note that i sent you with those
papers with those page numbers
and look at the at the note
and it gives the items then that's what
you want to look up
okay i'll do that thank you have to go
what they're modifying on the rsas
and then we've got to come up with what
it means to them
i add that the note
i think it was represent over who's
who said something about the references
they were they're using a draft hb2
that they have and she said that
she thought that the official hb2 would
be
have similar pagination and maybe it's
more
more importantly section numbers but
watch for that because
thank you on when we've done this
before and i don't know if we could get
it now but either have
gen iv or uh chris
shea extract out the sections of hb2
that we are supposed to look at and then
i have a question
and then send them to us i have a
question
about on whether if we look at the
um at the front pages
that are the index of hb2 which have no
page number references on and
you can't search by section number on
then uh can we uh
if we find something that we think deals
with the dedicated fund that we should
have done something about
or affects uh affects the tax revenue
could we add that to the list or not yes
this week and i'll probably stop this
afternoon because
when that meeting is happening on is to
take and pull out
from hb2 and put it into one document
those areas that they want us to look at
and then you know start looking at hb2
what other areas they didn't identify
that we should be looking at
and i'll add that to the document but
i'll get the first document out right
away thank you but we have to wait till
they've given us the official one with
its own pagination
on can i offer suggestions if i do the
same thing
once it's there thank you
not only you but any member of the
committee
uh anything else and then
march is a big month of revenues
and come probably around the 5th or so
we'll have a good idea i hope maybe the
28th
or 29th and then we need to start
looking
at what's happening and is that going to
affect
the projections that we have put in so
we really need to look at those things
and then we'll have to do the same thing
in april
wall street journal financial times
economist
anything that gives you a clue
it's going to affect us in new hampshire
and let's look into those things
uh 24 set of eyes and ears
all right okay
thank you everybody thank you norman
thank you
honor the ways and means committee
see you tomorrow have a good day
everybody
hi bob hey are you busy
you